welcome to this video playing now better
from Sweden and the last couple of times
with E Pfeifer I played the Kings gambit
and I want all three games that I that I
remember so let's try it once again aha
I must admit that I have no idea okay
take it take it at least I'm not a pawn
don't know yeah but this is I guess a
well-known theoretical line so let's
just develop
this pawn on f4 causes some is slightly
irritating it prevents me from
developing naturally wait what the heck
I can take on h7 of course yeah I could
have I could have done that
they moved before he's got the knight on
his head and I completely forgot about
that
check I'm not quite sure why or why he's
doing that now is this completely
completely terrible our wait wait wait
wait I see rook h8 is the idea and then
he wants to really wants to grab it and
this is funny so he wants to take on g5
mmm
um okay yeah you will take him
shouldn't there be some kind of attack
with the King on g5
they don't really see it I don't see a
substantial attack coming
I'm also lucky in attacking pieces of
course okay let's drop back and now the
king is on g5 holy hell what the heck is
going on that's some way to do that
maybe here threatening to take and
Bishop f4
okay if he drops back maybe Cooney six
but it's not really working
wait I can go here cutting off the six
rank undertaking the night and it's
really an attack on the night plus the
bishop is hanging so maybe maybe there
is something maybe he can play Knight
takes d4 now
ninety-four
Queen D 592 check King H one night g3
check takes on g3 rook h8 checking g1
Bishop c5 check and and hmm yeah Adam
losing maybe Knight takes d4 is working
nighty - check what the heck King here
my g3 check takes
okay change yeah this is working Bishop
c5 at the end okay so I would need to at
the end okay some completely different
move I have this irritates me what's now
okay let's not spend ages here grab some
material and the knight on f1 is it's
not the most reliable piece oh wait I
can take on f4 and look everyone the
shanks like this looks like a very very
direct attacking scheme and there's all
kinds of stuff hanging and I think it
could have taken on default I'm really
curious to check this afterwards with
the calm
yeah what what you can but you can't say
about the KS gambit whatever you want
but it gets it gets you entertaining
positions this much is is clear
so just stroke f5 now or is there some
way to do this with checks our Queen
Gianna where it's got 25
this look at five winning age three glad
should be come on it should be winning
really
yeah this one check and swinish walk we
know from it
Wow
this was a wild game black resigns shoo
alright so but I wanted here Knight a
gift okay it's it's annoying I switch on
the comm okay it doesn't come in
challengers come on I need to switch
this off here these challenges um
the croc doesn't want to take on d4 it
wasn't it working it looks I mean this
is losing yeah okay I saw this this line
check this is right this is what I saw
in the game check winning the Queen okay
so but I can take here the comp since
our oopsie fork and now it's no check
here okay I see this is unclear the comp
gives us a 0.4
hmm yeah no idea so that what Bishop b8
is winning just retreating yeah winning
is one thing but playing this position
is so another hmm look f3 g3 lady
yeah that's rookie of 6 yeah it looked
fishy of course but I thought after
query 6 I had something but maybe okay
with this this is not working here in 96
is the right and this is the right yeah
she's not difficult to see a rook
air-five wins
I wasn't completely sure about this one
and this is also amazing yeah there
needed to be a maid I mean after look at
5 this is too much
yeah a funny game I I think you enjoyed
it thanks